[MUSIC PLAYING]
So you can tell the age of shoes
just by looking at them.
Here's a new pair, and they've
got nice laces, with little
plastic caps on the end that
stop them from fraying.
These are a different story.
The laces are quite
old and worn away.
And on this one, the plastic
cap's gone completely, and the
ends are really frayed.
The same is true of
our chromosomes.
They've got caps on the end
called telomeres, and they
also wear away over time.
It turns out, that this is
actually a really important
mechanism for cells to know
how old they are.
So as the telomeres get shorter
and shorter, the cells
undergo a process called
replicative senescence.
Essentially, it's sitting there
not dividing, but also,
damaging the tissue around it.
And that's thought to contribute
to many of the
diseases of older age.
But there's an issue.
All our cells have telomeres
that get shorter
as the cells divide.
But we pass our chromosomes
onto our children.
So why don't they start
off life with
really short telomeres?
It turns out, this is all down
to an enzyme called telomerase
that's encoded on
chromosome 5.
And telomerase, essentially,
resets the biological clock.
Well, this is telomerase.
I know it looks ridiculous, but
it is, actually, a very
good representation
of the enzyme.
We know it has a mitten shape.
And inside is a template,
which allows it to make
repeats of DNA.
So we take DNA precursors, add
them into the telomerase
enzyme, and it simply adds
them on to the end of the
chromosome.
And we have multiple repeats on
the end of the chromosome,
protecting the rest
of the DNA.
So this is a fundamental
mechanism in germ cells and
stem cells.
But what happens when
it goes wrong?
Well, if you don't have enough
telomerase then the telomeres
are too short and the cells
will age prematurely.
On the other hand, if telomerase
is switched on in
all the cells of the body,
they all extend their
telomeres, the cells don't know
how old they are, they
will grow and divide
all the time.
And that can give
rise to cancer.
So telomerase is an incredibly
important enzyme.
Apart from a few unusual
exceptions, like onions and
fruit flies, it's really well
conserved all the way across
nature, from yeast to humans.
And now we know so much more
about what it is, and how it
works, there's a possibility
of being able to design new
drugs that can target telomerase
and allow people to
live healthier lives.